Yo tous le monde c'est squeezie !
Bah non C'est faux
DAMN !! Les gens c'est un plaisir de parler avec vous !
*Soupire*
Salut à tous les amis c'est JulienMéniellePokémon
Bon je sais pas comment commencer cette vidéo
Voilà
Oui, non, je voulais quand même juste vous dire 1 ou 2 trucs...
Voila
Ca fait deja 6 mois qu'on a cette relation sur internet.
Cette relation en ligne
et je me suis dit que...bon qu'il était peut être temps qu'on passe aux choses sérieuse vous et moi...
qu'il était peut être temps qu'on se rencontre...IRL   *musique romantique*
Donc dans les mois qui viennent pour ceux qu'ont envie, on va avoir l'occasion de se croiser.
Ca commence Vendredi 18 Novembre au salon européen de l'éducation à Paris Expo, Porte de Versailles.
Avec quelque collègue Youtubeur on fait une table ronde avec des professionnels de l'éducation,
mais on a aussi prévus un petit pique-nique avec vous tous, entre midi et 13H45
Tout le monde peut venir, l'entrée est gratuite, on se pose, on mange, on discute, ce sera à la cool.
Donc rendez-vous à midi sur le stand de "la ligue de l'enseignement" au salon européen de l'éducation
si vous ne parlez pas la bouche pleine, tout se passera bien.
Bon dans un registre un peu différent, en Avril je serais aussi à la Vidéo City Paris.
Bon je ne serais pas tout seul, il y aura deux, trois collègues avec moi, je ne sais pas si vous les connaissez...
Se sera les 8 et 9 Avril... Devinez où, à Paris Expo Porte de Versailles, incroyable !
Bon c'est dans longtemps, on aura l'occasion d'en re-parler
D'ici là et même après, on aura d'autre occasion de se croiser... Peut être même en Province, on sait pas...
Je peux pas en parler, on verra ça plus tard
En attendant un grand merci à tous d'être là, un grand merci à tous d'être aussi nombreux, d'être aussi sympa,
un grand merci à tous pour vos messages qui font chaud à mon petit appareil cardiovasculaire.
Je vous embrasse tous, à bientôt !
A oui, puis surtout, portez-vous bien !